[Music]
foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's
Tuesday and it's yet another live stream
here we are again yeah talking about Tom
Cruise every goddamn day talking about
well not every goddamn day we talk about
Tom Cruise but we do talk about Tom
Cruise like a lot
more than it's probably healthy I kind
of feel like Tom Cruise is a 13 o'clock
meme
not maybe not as much as Steven Seagal
is but you know
yeah but it's getting there that's like
that's like the our uh what do you call
that [ __ ] Mountain that has all the
faces so there you go why couldn't I
remember that it's called Mount Rossmore
it's Mount rosmore right yeah it's gonna
that's what hey that's what we should do
like we'll put it'll be your face and
then it'll be Steven Seagal Tom Cruise
and Crustle and Crustle and then like a
couple a couple more I just haven't
figured it figured out figured them out
yet
just all the [ __ ] crazy but look
anyway uh
so
I don't remember who it was but uh one
of our
new listeners requested
or he really didn't request it he he
um kind of recommended recommended I
feel like a couple people recommended
this movie which is why we ended up uh
watching it so uh we put it on and
watched it and uh it was good
Tom Cruise delivered the [ __ ]
stunning [ __ ] performance man Oscar
winning Tom Cruise Saves the World once
again what would we do without Tom
Cruise saving the world all the time
yeah man OT Powers
[Laughter]
OT powers that sounds like a porn name
[Laughter]
it takes OT powers to get that erect
and Viagra oh my God I just like
pictured a hole a whole [ __ ]
franchise step aside gentlemen step
aside
that OT Powers through
Tom Cruise is OT powered Scientology
porn star no it's me yeah
oh my God like I said you started I just
pictured like a whole franchise I just
got a little like [ __ ] I got a whole
idea people who don't know anything
about scientology probably have no idea
what we're talking about yeah but if
they do yeah yeah
I'm trying to tell just believes in
supernatural abilities that they call OT
Powers operating fate and Powers they're
spiritual Powers
OT power now one thing that I have to
say that because I said while we were
watching this movie I literally did not
say anything I was just quietly watching
the movie which is like something for me
because usually I'm so used to watching
MST and being a smart ass that I'll like
make little cracks throughout the movie
even if I like it but I was quietly
watching the movie and quite enjoying it
and Tom just like turns to me randomly
and says see this is a good movie like
you know why are you hating on Tom
Cruise or something like that you said
something like that [ __ ] what you say
yeah and it's like um
this is a good move
Tom Cruise can [ __ ] you're so hostile
Tom Cruise can deliver I could hear the
[ __ ] thought waves I literally was
not thinking that you were [ __ ]
busting on Tom Cruise for him for being
literally with nothing let a Tom be a
Tom man
it's the essence of Tom yeah he's in the
gang he's in the short guy
and the and the time I'm a short guy's
name Tom
uh oh Tom Tom was [ __ ] had built had
Paxton in it what's his name Bill Paxton
he was great in this I like I liked him
he was pretty good
uh had um [ __ ] who else was in this
Emily Blunt was that yeah it wasn't uh
who else was in this I thought it was
almost ours All-Star I mean those were
like the main kind of yeah
those are the main kind of like and it
was about
um
some dudes in the future
uh in the Army trying to stop an alien
invasion
and the aliens [ __ ] um
they have different different I guess
one of the abilities that they have is
that they're using time travel
yeah or they're like capable of
capability time or like yeah
and uh the military our military doesn't
know it
only Tom Cruise knows it well well Emily
Blunt knows because it happened to her
yeah right
they got some of this alien
[ __ ] blood in them alien juice yeah
and every time he died he'd wake up and
it would be the next it would be it
would be the same day so it was like
Groundhog Day
and they could reset the day or like a
video game where like where you die like
at a particular point then you start
over from that point right like with all
the new stuff that you've learned kind
of an interesting uh premise for the
movie uh because Tom Cruise plays this
guy he's I think he's a colonel or
something or a captain but he's in the
propaganda Department he's actually just
a it's like a Salesman and an actor and
he can [ __ ] yeah he's like media
liaison type of dude right he's making
commercials that [ __ ] get all these
dudes recruited
and uh his Commander decides to send him
to the front lines because he's sick of
looking at his punchable face yeah I
guess so I don't know I just made that
up and he's he's like no I ain't going
uh he's [ __ ] coward he runs they they
uh they they uh they rest his ass anyway
and they put him on the front lines
strip strip him down let's take his rake
away yeah to make him put it bust him
back down to private yeah which they
can't really do that to an officer but
that's okay it's it's a movie it's a
movie but um they did in this one
and uh what ends up happening is uh he
starts off as a shitty Soldier but every
time he dies because he got infected by
that blood and the initial attack
every time he dies he wakes up he gets
to do that day over again
and um
he becomes over time this [ __ ] badass
commando but part of it is is he knows
what's exactly what's going to happen so
he knows where to turn right or to turn
left depending on what alien kills him
and he's able to do that day over and
over again until he becomes a super
Commando
and find out more about the aliens and
there's like this alien control center
that it's like an alien that can that's
where it's commanding all the other
little aliens
um they're kind of like the Zerg or
something out of [ __ ] yeah it's kind
of like just like a brain that's kind of
like and they and it has yeah it's like
a hive mind and it knows and and uh
that's the place where it's uh
supervising the the [ __ ] time
time travel elements
well
the aliens know
that I guess Tom Cruise has the ability
to reset time
I guess they figure it out because I
think that they because it happened to
Emily Blunt's character first yeah but
then you lose it after like a certain
ability like if you lose a lot of blood
and don't die
then um it'll like seep out of your
blood so she lost the ability like after
a time but she actually like used that
ability to have like this big battle and
they it kind of like turned the tide
like because it's not even like stopping
an alien invasion the aliens have
already invaded and they're like kicking
our asses pretty much uh so her kind of
thing like they've pretty much
devastated like most of Europe and we're
trying to just like push them back so um
the fact that they kind of know what
we're up to but she said that they
didn't realize it took them like a
little while to realize like that she
could do the same thing that they could
do because of the blood and um so I
guess it took him a little while to like
hone in on her so I think the same thing
happened like with Tom Cruise yeah
because uh the aliens start focusing on
them to stop them
and time gets reset every day so they
only have a couple chances a day you
know but they do remember what happened
in the other timelines which is that's
odd time resets but you remember what
happened yeah well Tom Cruise remembers
nobody else does nobody else which like
I said is kind of like I was thinking
about it like when I was watching it
because I'm like man that must be a
giant pain in the ass so like every
single day Tom Cruise has to like get up
and he has to like have the same
discussions like all this and like
explain who he is and explain what's
going on and [ __ ] like that and just has
to get everybody up to speed like
quicker and quicker so they can like get
farther and farther like toward their
goal of like defeating the aliens you
know they called it the Omega yeah yeah
yeah it's the Omega complex it's just an
alien thing they got to destroy it so it
it's I don't even they show it a little
bit it's just swirling ball it's almost
like a McGuffin really but they
eventually get to it and they destroy it
and um he saves the [ __ ] world like
Tom Cruise post is Tom Cruise supposed
to save the planet using his OT Powers
[ __ ]
yeah I still want to see uh map top gun
Maverick everybody says it's great soon
they'll they'll have that on Amazon
Prime I'll read it
it's an enjoyable movie
uh I'd have to say certain parts it's
well made
um the only my only gripe about this
movie is that the the physical designs
of the aliens is pretty generic it's
just they're just balls of tentacles
that swirl around and Kill [ __ ] which
I've seen that several times it reminds
me of some other aliens from another
movie it was just a damn black ball with
eyes and [ __ ] metal tentacles coming
out of the back of it is killing I don't
forgot what movie that was I know I kind
of feel like I've seen that design or a
similar design before right maybe this
might be out of left field but if any of
you guys remember it was a horror movie
that came out uh probably like several
years ago called Splinter and it was
kind of I don't even remember if it was
like aliens or something but it was kind
of like some kind of alien
creature or something but it was kind of
like that where it was kind of black and
it just had like all these little
spiders and [ __ ] but yeah it did kind of
remind me of I mean they looked kind of
cool but generic yeah not yeah they
nowhere near as say
um
as creative as like the xenomorph for uh
you know or
the [ __ ] yaota [ __ ] Predator
looking thing you know I mean I think
they should have hired some dudes to
come up with um with a better alien
design
um it's in general the movie's kind of
like across a team
aliens
Starship Troopers yeah it had a Starship
do you use the kind of vibe to it yeah
and uh
like Caddyshack Groundhog Day you know
what's his name Bill Murray keeps waking
up it's the same day over and over and
he's doing the same thing where he's
like learning like information that he
learns every day to like you have to
figure out how to break the cycle right
but he's well he's trying to news isn't
trying to break the cycle he's trying to
protect it he's just trying to win the
mission
in this one but it's it's but other than
that man other than a couple little weak
spots in this movie most of them not
being really important because it's an
enjoyable movie other than that it's
it's an enjoyable movie yeah I kind of
feel like the design of the aliens
wasn't really like make or break because
to be honest they weren't really like
the main focus like they were really
mostly focused on the characters and
like the human struggle so it didn't
really matter like what the aliens
looked like and I kind of think too that
the way the aliens moved because they
were pretty much like you said just kind
of like a ball with tentacles on it and
they usually like move so fast that you
couldn't really get a beat on what they
look like anyhow yeah they just jump up
out of the ground but we just spin
around and just cut things into pieces
and then vanish
I think they were supposed to at least
like from what I skimmed over on the
Wikipedia page I think that they were
supposed to be made of like glass or
Crystal or something like that like
which you know that would cut things
like when they when they like went
through it which yeah I guess okay so um
I don't know if you knew this but this
is based on a novel that came out in
2004 it was a Japanese a light novel
which I was like what the [ __ ] is a
light novel I guess it's like the
Japanese equivalent of like a y a like a
young adult yeah okay
um and it's called All You Need Is kill
yeah and that came out in 2004 and then
they released it in 2009 in the United
States so obviously in the book I
haven't read the book but um the
characters are much much younger so when
because it's a y a novel so uh I guess
when they when Warner Brothers or
whoever like bought the rights they had
to like up I think Brad Pitt was
actually the first choice uh as the main
character but he didn't do it he didn't
want to do it what year did this come
out 2014 okay 2014. okay the thing about
this
um yeah so they changed it uh I guess
they were gonna call it after the novel
which is called All You Need Is kill but
I guess they did like um you know all
the you know what do you call them like
surveys and stuff like that and people
didn't like that title yeah so they
changed it to Edge of Tomorrow
um it's also known it's also known as
Live Die Repeat
okay and they were thinking about making
a sequel
um I don't know if it's gonna happen now
I think they were talking about it as
recently as 2018 2019 but I think
earlier this year they decided they were
going to do like a TV series spin-off
like maybe a prequel right like how the
Ayla because I kind of feel like that
would probably be the best way to go
with this one if you were gonna do
another movie in this universe I kind of
feel like it'd probably better do a
prequel and like figure out how the
aliens first got there and like maybe
the origin and stuff like that you know
what I mean because I I don't think they
should do the same thing over again I
really liked this concept like even
though it's essentially like the same
concept like you said as Groundhog Day
you know I mean where it's one person
living the same day over and over again
and using that to
um learn how to get better and like
learn how to defeat like the big bad you
know what I mean so I like that concept
but I don't know how you would
incorporate that like working again like
you'd have to do well you could still do
like time travel or time warping like if
you did a sequel prequel whatever but I
kind of feel like you'd have to go in
like a slightly different Direction with
it maybe I don't know
I liked it it was um
it's as good as Oblivion
um they're two different very different
movies I think yeah I think I like
Oblivion a little bit better a little
bit more my style although if I was in
my 20s I'd probably like this because
this was an action movie
oh very much so very much so it's just
action action action action action
um uh Oblivion was uh a little more it
had action in it but it was a little
more kind of like uh psychological had a
bunch of weird twists and stuff in it
like you know you find out that the Tom
Cruise you're rooting for is a [ __ ]
clone there's lots of those yeah that
was fun we got lots of those yeah we got
extra Tom cruises just laying around in
the attic and [ __ ] yeah and he killed
another one of himself he had to kill
another clone of himself at one point in
the movie this is you know and he's
trying to save the planet that way
because it flat had been taken over by
aliens and they replaced
they replaced or
got taken over by aliens and they made a
bunch of clothes to Tom Cruise which of
course if you're gonna you're if you're
gonna make a clone to humans it's gonna
be tough I mean he's got to be the best
top of the last year where's the best
human okay okay we're gonna make [ __ ]
talk clones a time and then they made
him like they made all those clowns like
slaves to the aliens to run this [ __ ]
system that they had and um they had him
out there fighting a invite invading
aliens but turns out he was fighting
humans you know he didn't know but uh he
was it was that was a pretty spoiler
Flair
he didn't realize he was working for the
aliens
um they had him in they had him in The
Matrix
but uh
no this was a decent movie decent movie
um I don't know if this is one that I
would personally re-watch
I think I I think I've seen all I need
to see this one I'd re-watch
I might re-watch this one I mean the
thing I liked about this one was that I
liked that they made Tom Cruise
unlikable at the beginning yeah like
he's cowardly and kind of uh
kind of arrogant he's like he's like oh
not me I ain't doing that [ __ ] yeah he's
like yeah well you know like he's like
that like he's good at that because like
I said that's probably what he's really
like in real life but it's like I like
that he was willing to be like that at
the beginning and so he got his ass
kicked like a bunch of times and also
like you have to I also kind of enjoyed
I know it's gonna sound [ __ ] up but I
actually kind of enjoyed um when he was
training with Emily Blunt's character
um that she just like kept shooting him
in the head over and over yeah every
time he [ __ ] up well because like I
said well he was getting his legs busted
up and he couldn't he couldn't complete
the mission with busted up legs right so
it's like okay starting over
yeah to to save what Jenny said okay
because I'm gonna have to [ __ ] stand
up for Tom Cruise one for the millionth
time if you uh she said that he probably
was like the original character at the
very beginning no people didn't know him
so he's more like the heroes that he
plays
that's what he's really like well I
don't know I'm just speculating
Scientology because he's just so good at
being smarmy
said that well he's a dick
some people have uh one of the
ex-scientologists that knows him real
well
describes him as diabolical
that he's diabolical yeah he's mean uh
but yeah that I can believe yeah but
he's not cowardly he's very competent
he's basically
like a military guy
um because you know they
scientologists run as a [ __ ]
paramilitary kind of organization but
it's not a real what it's they think
they're Jedi all right but he's he's
probably a dick
um because he's superiority complexes
and
what I mean that's what I mean it's just
like even though he's like a coward at
the beginning it's he does have a
superiority complex and he's arrogant
because he's like oh well like like he
kind of feels like combat is almost like
beneath him that's kind of the way that
he's kind of like coming it's in the
movie I mean the character yeah but
evidently he's not like that real life
and and Tom Tom Cruise is good with guns
he's very good with guns you see well
and see he did like all his own stunts
in this one too Emily blunted as well
like she trained a lot like to to do
this as well and I don't I don't [ __ ]
um
I don't doubt one bit that [ __ ] Tom
Cruise would get into a gunfight if he
you know what I mean to save Scientology
or to say yeah he'd do it [ __ ] right
yeah he'd do it
just like any other Soldier would so I
would I don't really put it I don't
think he's a coward oh no I didn't say
that I just said that I you know what I
was saying was that he plays roles
really well where he's like an arrogant
douche yeah and I said that's probably
yeah that's closer to what he's like
he's been described as a tool oh
[Laughter]
gotta say he's competent yeah he could
fly aircraft he can shoot guns yeah like
I said those two things are not mutually
exclusive so it's like I don't like I
hope you don't think that I'm implying
yeah because I said that he was a tool
or something like that that he can't do
all the [ __ ] I know he can do all this
[ __ ] but that doesn't mean that he's not
an [ __ ] like he comes across like an
arrogant [ __ ] probably an [ __ ]
yeah that's all I'm saying I'd have to
reserve judgment time Maddie but you see
we're in a short guy Mafia so I'd start
[ __ ] with him then he start [ __ ]
with me to [ __ ] with each other and then
we work it out
bruh you know are you gonna introduce
yourself by your by your new porn name
OT power just [ __ ] pop my dick
my dick off
a dick off I don't have a dick off so
yeah
get to measure and take
they're gonna make rules and everything
no stretching yeah
you'd probably laugh at that [ __ ]
maybe or maybe or maybe
he'd say that that was [ __ ] out
ethics yeah so that's out of Ethics yeah
he probably I kind of feel like he
doesn't really have that much of a sense
of humor I know as much about that kind
of stuff
you're out ethics man you're you're an
SP yeah you know [ __ ] that's
homosexual activity you say some [ __ ]
like that yeah he probably that's what I
mean he he seems like he'd be a little
bit yeah he tried to write me up he'd
try to write me up some kind of [ __ ]
report and [ __ ] sending out to the
[ __ ] yeah he said the office of
special Affairs yeah that's their
version of like the [ __ ] that's what
he would do FBI and [ __ ] he's a homo
Tom's a homo yeah that's what he'd say
thank you Ian England for the Super Chat
oh what's he saying how y'all are having
a black hope I guess he means hope y'all
are having a blast this Christmas yeah
we're having a pretty good time we're
having a pretty good time Hugo also says
there's a horror movie happy death day
with the same time travel concept
concept yeah I think I said that when I
was uh watching it actually I really
really like the Happy death day uh
movies it's kind of like the same thing
it's like groundhog day except like it's
a slasher and that's like Charming but I
kind of feel like
um as of tomorrow from what I heard
about the original novel that not only
were the character is much younger
but it was also like much darker
so when they made it into a movie they
kind of like
I know a lot of people die and stuff
like that but they did kind of like
lighten it up with a lot of humor and
stuff and I think maybe to
I I think that was probably to the
benefit of the movie I mean I it's not
like super deep or anything like that
but it's like a pretty enjoyable just
like action sci-fi movie that I kind of
feel like and it seems like it's crazy
because it made a lot of money I don't
think it made quite it made like 350
million dollars or something like
ridiculous amount
um I don't think it made quite as much
as they were expecting
um and it actually did a little bit
better overseas I think than it did here
but
um the thing about it is that I don't
think I read a bad review of it like all
the critics at the time like thought it
was [ __ ] great like in a lot of
critics like picked it as like the one
of their top 10 movies of that year you
know what I mean yeah uh one of the
things about the movie that I thought
was cool is it is that uh they had some
the equipment that they were using you
could tell that it was real Starship
Troopers inspired like the book not so
much the Starship Trooper movies yeah
powered armor they were uh they had
basically kind of like
kind of like drop ship type stuff which
the Starship Trooper books they were
shooting them out of a damn Cannon and
re-entering into the atmosphere and the
capsules
[Laughter]
yeah orbital spaceship and [ __ ] which
you look at this you go man they could
they could do Starship Troopers again
and do it a lot better than they did oh
I'm sure they'll get around to remaking
yeah they need to do that like it was in
the well
the book didn't have much backline death
through that was over pretty quickly but
they could they could just make it about
kind of death
but that would be that would be pretty
good um it's just kind of cool to see
what they can do with CG
some of it was kind of hard to watch
some of it's happening so fast you're
not really able to tell what had
happened
um
also kind of like
some of the stuff that they do
in CG movies is they pack the entire
screen with action
which is unrealistic uh you don't have
that many things happening in frame in
real life I remember when I joined a
service that was looking at all the
devil propaganda [ __ ] recruitment
videos and they got you they got the
dude [ __ ] chomping out of the play
with the rifle and the parachute and
another dude coming out of a helicopter
and a next to a tank with [ __ ] Jets
and Rockets and [ __ ] you've never seen
kangaroo that can fly that's all
happening it's all happened and in one
spot man in real life you never see any
of that [ __ ] together at the same time
everything's spread out yeah but they're
trying to make it look like exciting
exciting yeah yeah look at all this [ __ ]
it's just advertising yeah that's what
they've done ever since the birth of
advertising yeah they're trying to make
[ __ ] like seem cooler than it actually
is because reality is kind of boring
most of the time you know not gonna lie
well
this the CG based [ __ ] war movies do
that a lot it's kind of unbelievable
they pack too much [ __ ] and then you
look at a [ __ ] real uh a live action
War move it's very effective you know
like
um bucket apocalypse now you know what I
mean that's really looks more like that
that's that's what it looks like in real
life
where you just see [ __ ] smoke trails
and tracers coming out of the dam
Woodline into a boat that's you might
only just see that you know or some dude
drops ahead in your lap and that's it
you know
that's enough you know just the way it's
shot I wish they'd kind of get back to
that realism not so much
I don't know not so much [ __ ] yeah
but this is like a Sci-Fi time Loop
movie and it's kind of based on a novel
that the author the novel said that his
whole idea was from playing video games
yeah like dying and starting over yeah
so it's kind of like he used that
concept like for all they're all sorry
they're all kind of haven't they all
have a tone of video game tone to me now
though right all those real heavily CGI
action movies like the DC movies all or
not DC the the Marvel movies all kind of
seem like a like a video game to me
yeah they just don't come across this
film
well I mean there's gonna be there's
gonna be that because it's they're kind
of like trying to appeal to the same
audience as like you know Gamers and
stuff like that are the ones that watch
generally are the ones that watch these
kind of movies you know what I mean yeah
so I didn't mind that I mean even though
it was I'm not like a huge I'm not
hugely into video games or anything like
that and I'm not really hugely into big
spectacle movies like this but actually
for that genre this was actually like a
really good one and I got like really
into because I think too that even
though I'm not you know even though I'm
not the world's biggest fan of Tom
Cruise
um he was actually really good in this
like I said I like that he was allowed
himself to be kind of a like a cowardly
douche at the beginning yeah and so you
actually saw him getting his ass kicked
and failing like over and over and over
and over again and it took him like a
really really long time to get to a
point where he you know was good at what
he was doing and he like actually
learned to be a good person and [ __ ]
like that like over the course of the
movie so I thought that was really cool
that you got to see like the learning
curve I also thought it was good that
because a lot of times with movies that
have this kind of thing like a repeating
time Loop you have the factor where you
know oh it's going to get repetitive
because you're seeing the same thing
like happening over and over again just
like it with slight variations but I
think this movie did a good job of
getting the point across without making
it too like oh here's this again you
know what I mean like I think it I think
it did a good job of that and then like
once it got to you know the halfway
point or a little bit farther then it
would started getting to a point where
you know they were getting into new
territory like it wasn't like the same
[ __ ] over and over because they kept
getting farther and farther each time
and then sometimes they didn't even show
like some of the variations like you
know you just knew it because of
exposition like Tom Cruise would be like
yeah we've been here this many times
before and [ __ ] like that
so I thought it was handled really well
could have probably done without the
romance angle you know but it was all
right it wasn't it wasn't like overdone
or anything like that it was like pretty
subtle it's just it was just one of
those things that's like oh do we really
have to like put a break in every single
girl he did in the end save the girl
and the girl didn't know it he'd had to
explain it to her yeah nobody would have
known that he saved the world because
[ __ ] time got reset
yeah I mean pretty much so so not only
did he go through all of that and then
he like you know all of that trouble
like over and over the same day and then
he saves the world after this really
difficult [ __ ] and getting killed
over and over yeah but nobody is gonna
know nobody knew yeah that he that he
did that yeah but he was okay with it
that was part of heroism right that's
what I mean that's what I mean like how
he learned to be a good person because
it's like he didn't care that nobody
knew that it didn't matter the world it
didn't matter that nobody knew he did it
yeah but yeah I thought that was cool
but yeah so this was actually like um
the guy that directed this Doug Lyman or
Limon I don't remember how to pronounce
his last name he also did the original
uh born identity among other things
like that first one yeah uh he did
swingers which actually I haven't seen
in a long time but I remember really
liking that and he also made jumper from
2008. like I said they have been
thinking about doing a sequel or prequel
to this but I don't know if it's gonna
be like a movie or and I was going
um he seemed like he was attached like a
couple of years ago and he seemed open
to it I don't know if they're gonna do
that or not but like I said they might
go a series Route and I don't know if
Tom Cruise would be in a series maybe he
would nowadays I just kind of I feel
like he's a movie guy but I was gonna
say too like the mech suits that they
wore they actually built those and they
said they weighed like 85 pounds so they
actually did have to wear them okay and
they said that um so everybody that was
wearing them they said they it took so
long to like get them off of the actors
that when they were doing a break or
they were like resting in between shoots
they had to kind of like hang them like
up on some hooks or something like that
like to take the pressure off because it
was like so [ __ ] heavy yeah I just
thought that was really funny because I
just thought of like little Tom Cruise
and Emily Blunt like hanging there
they're [ __ ] suits they're [ __ ] 85
pound suits that's like pretty [ __ ]
awesome and answer anybody's question no
those suits will never exist even if
they could do it they wouldn't they they
wouldn't use them not in combat
because if you're going to put that much
money in something like that it's not
going to be a suit it's going to be a a
robot and it's probably just going to
have tracks in other words it's gonna be
a little tank you don't you just yeah
you don't need a person you might as
well like bypass that bypass that whole
person the whole person thing yeah you
won't need it
and what would be more
realistic is something like a suit like
uh like the storm troopers from Star
Wars
but it would be ballistic resistant you
know something like that that would they
would do that with Optics and
Communications and computer stuff inside
the helmets everybody can talk to one
another
you might have a little bit of
filtration so CS gas and things like
tear gas we didn't smoke you wouldn't
have to worry about that and um it would
be real bullet resistant and it but it'd
be real light it would probably be
climate controlled something that where
you could wear it in a tropical
environment and it'd be cool
it would have to be something like that
that'd be nice I could do with that in
the in the summer in Florida that's
probably 40 years that's probably 40 or
50 years away and it would be expensive
it'd be still be expensive
and the whole idea of infantry is that
they're cheap
cheap and Expendable and they can get
into little nooks and crannies and if
you don't need them to go into nooks and
crannies you blow it up with an
artillery piece it's real basic
technology doesn't really work real well
in combat if you're a technophile you're
gonna lose
you just you want quantity
quantity has a quality all its own
you blow [ __ ] up your [ __ ] get blown up
and it's instantly replaced with other
cheap [ __ ] that also blows other things
up a bunch of dudes get killed and
nobody cares they just replace them with
more dudes if you had more dudes you
have the better
well I kind of feel like they did kind
of like obliquely address this in this
movie because I mean at the point at the
beginning when Tom Cruise got thrown
into the battle
um they were essentially kind of like I
feel like the higher-ups were kind of
like yeah they knew that the aliens were
just gonna kick their asses but they
just kept throwing more guys at him you
know what I mean even though they were
all getting killed yeah well in Real
Warfare that's what it's like well yeah
that's what I mean so they did that's
what I meant by what they didn't they
obliquely like addressed that in this
movie where they were just kind of like
yep we're just sending everybody out
there even though they'll probably all
get like annihilated and United States
hasn't really been in a real world war
since Korea Korea was that was [ __ ] up
World War II in Korea and really Russia
did most of it in World War II they got
[ __ ] slaughtered
they killed more Germans than anything
and uh our war was mostly against the
Japanese and that was on islands and
that was
Annihilation but it was within a limited
Spectrum there were no civilians in the
area which most of the time depending on
where they were but on those little
Islands there weren't any civilians and
that's a totally different Dynamic
usually there's civilians involved
usually
Richard Brown said have you seen Time
Crimes I don't think so I've heard of it
but I don't think I've ever seen it Ian
England said Tom I'm with you on the
lack of realism in a lot of war movies
they make so many decisions and make no
tactical sense yeah like I said I mean
I'm willing to I'm willing to suspend my
disbelief in movies just because as long
as it's not like egregious just because
like I said real life is usually doesn't
look that cinematic and it looks kind of
like boring so I'm willing to like let
them just be like yeah it's not entirely
realistic but they're going with what
looks better or what's more exciting or
interesting or whatever so that's fine
with me and honestly like I kind of feel
like the the big battle set piece that
happens in this movie like toward the
beginning like where they're all like on
the beach like storming the beach and
they're just getting their [ __ ] you
know they're they're getting torn out of
the frame by the all the [ __ ] uh
aliens they kind of based that a little
bit on uh D-Day you know they want us
late and they wanted that kind of like
look to it
as well like where the uh aliens were
coming but it's like yeah that was kind
of funny the way
uh uh you know he would care like every
every go around like sometimes he would
save that guy that like got hit by the
[ __ ] uh the transport plane that fell
and sometimes he was like ah [ __ ] it
I'll get him like that stuff you know
what I mean well there were so many of
those guys getting killed right now
right
and then well because the thing about it
because I'm sitting there wondering
because they're like okay well the go
around where he actually gets to the end
like and fights the big boss because
like I said it's kind of like a video
game so the version where he actually
gets to the end whoever died in that
version would be dead in real life but
if he if he got killed and then had to
start over again then he had like the
opportunity to like save different
people because he he they I think
somebody somewhere
um did the mathematical uh calculation
about how many times it would have taken
him like to get through all of these
possibilities and stuff I don't even
remember how much it was like some
ridiculous amount of time I think I
would have gone crazy like living the
same day over and over that many times
but you know what I mean he was
determined so he just got through the
whole thing but
um oh my goodness hello thumbs up hey
what are you guys doing she popped her a
little out of it could you see your
little head of this I don't know I
didn't see I didn't see it either
because I was like looking at her she
was making all that noise yeah you can
see her hand I just it was on the delay
here a little hip hop
hey what are you guys doing yeah man she
was like I don't know what her deal was
last night but she just did not want to
leave Mama alone she rolled over to
Middle night
she was on her side and pookie was
standing on her shoulder just yeah and I
said get down she just looked at me like
no no I'm standing on Mama yeah yeah
[ __ ] funny I think she slept between
my feet like almost all night and like
she came up and like slept on my chest
too for a little while which she doesn't
usually do she usually she's a big girl
she likes to
she likes to sleep on her own she
usually sleeps in um her little bowl the
little fuzzy Bowl in her cat tree that's
where she usually sleeps she doesn't
usually sleep in the bed with us but I
don't know why she did last night it
wasn't it was cold last night but it
wasn't
colder than it was the night before that
so I don't know what the deal was but um
but yeah so this was actually like a
pretty damn good flick I thought now we
rented this right
like did we did we pay to rent this yeah
okay so it was like 3.99 or however much
it was on Amazon Prime yeah but um yeah
it yeah it is I really I really liked it
a lot and like I said that's cut that's
a lot coming for me because this isn't
my preferred genre and it's not my
preferred actor
um but I thought it was like a cool
concept and I really liked I don't know
I just really like the way they
they pulled it off I thought it was like
really entertaining I thought it uh it
was it was up to Tom Cruise standards
you know what I mean he's in he's in
good movies it's it's you know
it's a good Tom Cruise movie he just he
won't be in a shitty movie
yeah now that you mentioned that I don't
think I've ever seen him in a shitty
movie no so you got to give him that I
mean the dude's in his 50s right yeah he
doesn't need the money
yeah you know he's got money but he
doesn't really so he
can yeah he's he can afford to like
right yeah she is yeah
yeah I mean he's been well okay he was
in the mummy and you like that movie but
I didn't I like the movie but I'm not
but it wasn't like a shitty movie in the
sense that uh you know Manos the hands
of Fate was a [ __ ] it was a good movie I
think the timing was bad on that movie
and it didn't quite come out the right
time or I didn't love the concepts
behind it I think they should have gone
a different direction but there was a
lot of stuff I liked about that movie
they I think they were trying to do like
the MCU but with the with the monster
with the monsters and uh I think it
could have worked but
there was just
I just you know there just wasn't enough
Buzz I guess people weren't that
interested in it well and like I said I
kind of felt like they were going too
much they were leaning too hard into the
MCU Direction where they were trying to
make it more like a generic action maybe
I'm like I'm like we've already got like
tons of those we've already got like
lots of franchises like do something
different should have been a spooky
movie that's what I'm saying they should
have made it more like a horror movie
yeah that's what and I said that before
because if you're just gonna Dr just
make like a generic if you're gonna turn
the mummy into just like a generic big
Sci-Fi Action Movie it's like yeah we've
already got like loads of those yeah
that's yeah you're right that's probably
what it was yeah it's just it didn't do
enough to like distinguish itself and so
I was like so you're turning off like
your main you know audience of like
people like me that are into horror
movies or like or wanted to see like a
new take on the universal monsters but
not as a Sci-Fi Action Movie because
like I said if I wanted to watch the
Sci-Fi Action movie I watched sci-fi
yeah Russell Crowe was in that and he's
uh [ __ ] Dr Jekyll yeah he was like
the only part of that movie yeah he's
[ __ ] oh and I liked the look of the
of the Mummy the the woman I liked that
I liked the look she looked cool but
she's talking and [ __ ] he starts
turning in to hide and I'm going yeah
yeah that's right you know I mean
[ __ ] that's what we were watching
that maybe I said oh my God he's like
you Tom yeah
what you want you know
Deanna ball what's making you that that
reminded me of you is almost as much as
Jack Nicholson like doing the thing in
The Shining where he's like yeah like
down the hall and [ __ ] like that like
going toward the golden room I was like
that's kind of like you yeah
but uh no [ __ ] and I was waiting for
Crow to like throw a phone I would have
said okay look how funny would that have
been like
when you started [ __ ] turning in
maybe they asked him and he said no
absolutely not I'm not doing anything
you're gonna [ __ ] throw that phone
suck it just Chuck it yeah yeah [ __ ] I
want to see [ __ ] maybe they did maybe
they asked him and he's like no I'm not
there I refuse to throw a phone you know
throw the [ __ ] phone
yeah yeah and then they just like try to
make it mad
did you get that on film
favorite comes into town and I'm gonna
[ __ ] go see him I'll [ __ ] have a
big old [ __ ] phone
you're gonna get this [ __ ] on camera run
up just hand him a phone so throw it
right stop throw it throw it Russell
throw it go along
see what he does
he probably hits you in the face
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then you'll be sorry tell him he
needs to go on a diet you need to go on
tonight
yeah that'll really go yeah he throws
the [ __ ] phone
win-win yeah
ah Richard Brown said The Wolf Man with
Anthony Hopkins was good I've been
wanting to um
to uh review that actually because we
did Mary Shelley's Frankenstein the
Kenneth brownout of one
um which actually I quite like other
than we reviewed that a little while ago
but I kind of feel like um we hadn't
done the wolf man but I remember that
being good because I saw it in the
theater and like back when it came out
uh Ian England said yeah everyone wants
to be Disney Marvel now I'm so [ __ ]
over that crap yeah it's like you know
those movies are fine but it's like not
every movie has to be like that movie
like I don't think they're funny let's
have some different types of movies I
don't even think Marvel movies are any
good anymore I just I think it's played
out I mean I know it's hard because
they're always trying to like because
you know the Marvel movies consistently
like make all the money so they're just
kind of like oh we want to do more stuff
like that because we also want to make
all the money but you know there comes a
point yeah there comes a point where
it's just like diminishing returns
everybody's like look if I wanted to see
a Marvel movie I'm just gonna watch a
Marvel movie I want to see like
something different this is a different
franchise it's been going on for a long
time it's getting kind of stale same
thing with [ __ ] Harry Potter ratchets
men are going on for too long man I mean
they love it but I
I wouldn't see it
yeah well it's not like I said it's
never been I I'm not hugely into like
these big kind of like 10 volt sort of
movies yeah
yeah Ben said the Wolfman was great we
should probably do that because that
come out
um God it was a while back okay I kind
of feel like it was mid 2000s okay so
it's more recent or 2009 something like
that all right that was one with Benicio
del Toro right
I mean I think it was
but um because I'm pretty sure I saw it
in the theater but yeah maybe we should
like um do that one like on the matinee
next week because I've been wanting to
re-watch that one anyway I don't know
what streaming service it's on Hugo said
check out the new Universal werewolf by
night with uh Gail Garcia I think
they're trying again to start that
monster franchise like I said I'm not a
verse I really like the idea of like a
dark universe or like the extended
Universal monster so I think it's cool
but I think that they should make it
scary they should make them horror
movies yeah don't make them like action
I don't even do like that [ __ ] like Van
Helsing or underworld or don't do that
kind of [ __ ] either make them like
pretty much straight up horror movies
you know I think it would be a lot
better like make them scary
because we don't really have anything
like that they evidently like we I saw
the trailer to that morbius thing and I
thought I thought more abuse was going
to be good and then they they came back
and they just said it was terrible
yeah we didn't wonder if it really was
terrible I mean it might not have been
terrible maybe you look good yeah but
for some reason they just said it was
terrible
yeah I mean there could be a lot of
reasons for that I just like I don't
know it looked like a good vampire I
usually just like to see a movie myself
because sometimes sometimes I like stuff
that other people don't like and vice
versa
yeah but that was also kind of like an
action movie yeah I do I would just like
to see like a big franchise like
utilizing the universal monsters that
wasn't necessarily an action movie it
could have action in it I'm not saying
that but I don't want it to be like all
the other action movies like with all
the CGI and all this other kind of crap
I think it would be better because we've
had that we have that already
I'd bring back blade you get the good
guy to play blade and you make that you
make that [ __ ] based as [ __ ] no no no
[ __ ] in it just real violent
scary
yes scary yeah it's scary that's what I
think it's real violent
um [ __ ] with a good uh uh [ __ ]
updated Gothic Motif to it it'd be real
cool yeah it'd be badass if like they
could do it right yeah
kind of like with with the uh kind of
the same kind of visual Style with that
new that newer Batman that they did
which I think was just called the Batman
or something yeah we saw it it wasn't
bad yeah it wasn't super compelling but
I like for the look yeah you know where
they kind of brought back like a 70s
kind of look to it the car or the
Batmobile looked like something by the
70s and they had uh little what's her
name Lenny Kravitz's daughter was
Catwoman it was it was okay I thought I
thought the look was good
the story was kind of
yeah meddling middling but you know
Ben says do that with blade Ben says in
the 90s Marvel had a whole horror phase
with the midnight Sons dozens of
horror-related titles it was okay while
it lasted see well there you go they
could even do their own [ __ ] horror
offsheet I don't know
yeah Camp guy said morbius was one
unbelievable CGI fight scene after
another worst CGI I've ever seen yes I
kind of feel like the yeah it's just
stuff like that is just too reliant on
CGI I kind of feel like they need to go
back
toward like more atmosphere based and
like more horror based don't make
everything I don't want to see like a
whole bunch of fight sequences with a
bunch of like
weightless things like flying around on
the screen I don't need that I'll need
more of that a couple days ago I watched
that third
um Riddick movie I think it was just
called Riddick
and Vin Diesel produced that one and uh
the the the
Blu-ray that Jen got me and had the uh
Extended Cut or like the director's cut
and it's good I liked it
it's longer by about a half hour than
the uh because we saw at the theater
also I liked it we was fighting the damn
scorpions in the [ __ ] water and [ __ ]
what's up
[Laughter]
what you talking about yeah but um
yeah we saw another Vin Diesel one
in the theater was in the theater or no
it was just one of the
is that the one that they just put
directly to the [ __ ] I think they put
that one directly to streaming right
where he was kind of a when you glow in
red hot it was some kind of superhero
and he'd glow red hot he'd had some kind
of [ __ ] biotech in it and brought him
back in the dead remember that
Vin Diesel vaguely I think he'd get shot
he'd get hot hotter or something I don't
remember oh I kind of remember that yeah
I'd have to see it again I forgot I
remember it being okay but I guess it
didn't really make much of an impression
because I totally forgot this yeah I
thought it was okay I liked it at the
time but then I immediately forgot it
just like all the rest of those damn
Marvel movies yeah a lot of times that's
what like you enjoy them while you're
watching me was like oh that's pretty
cool but then like you know a day later
I'm just like what the [ __ ] happened to
that right
you know yeah
that's okay but it just depends on like
what you want out of your movies I guess
all right so uh are you ready to wrap it
up yeah okay so uh I'm gonna lift a
little bit okay well you can just do
whatever the hell you want to
um yeah so tomorrow's Wednesday so
tomorrow is the main show and tomorrow
night the show is about Timothy McVeigh
okay yeah and the Oklahoma City bomb all
right I'm ready for it so we're gonna
talk about that tomorrow evening so
thanks everybody for dropping by thanks
for super chats and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow evening good night